foreign  set into motion the salvation's Army  Seeds of Hope program opened its Art  Exhibit at City Hall this evening in  honor of human trafficking awareness  month now this exhibit showcasing  artwork created by human trafficking  survivors with each flower painted  symbolized in the future they hold  blooms for themselves  when someone can see something like this  so beautiful  with with you know a story behind it  that they can be inspired to know that  healing is possible when these victim  survivors learn to tap into their true  power and find purpose in everything  that's happened to them as of 2020  Nevada had the second highest rate of  human trafficking in the country  according to the Nevada independent with  sex trafficking being most common in  Nevada the Art Exhibit is open to the  public located up on the second floor of  the city hall building